تحت الجبال او في جوف الارض تخفي ايران
قواعدها العسكريه ومواقعها النوويه
ومخزونها من الصواريخ الباليستيه ليبقى
بعيدا عن اعين العالم ورادراته ولكن مع
دقه صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه تمكنت نيويورك
تايمز من الكشف عن احدث اضافه الى عالم
ايران السري وهي قاعده جويه جديده اطلق
عليها اسم
تستضيف هذه القاعده حاليا طائرتين
عسكريتين احداهما نموذج بالحجم الطبيعي
لطائره سوخوي 35 المقاتله الروسيه الاكثر
تقدما والمصنفه ضمن اخطر المقاتلات سيطره
جويه في العالم
تقول نيويورك تايمز انها اعتمدت في
تحليلها لصور الاقمار الاصطناعيه وكذلك عن
مقاطع فيديو للترويج الاعلاني ازاح
الستاره عن قاعده
الاسبوع الماضي فمنذ سبتمبر 2022 روج
مسؤولون ايرانيون
نيه بلادهم شراء 24 طائره من طراز سوخوي
35 من موسكو ورغم ان روسيا لن تؤكد هذه
الصفقه المفترضه الا ان التفاصيل التي
تضمنتها صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه اضافه
للفيديو الدعائي تشير الاستعداد ايران
لاستقبال هذه الطائرات المقاتله قريبا
وعلى الارجح في نهايه العام وفقا لنيورك
تايمز تم الكشف عن قاعده الجويه لاول مره
في عام 2013
بمقاطعه هرمزجان الايرانيه محفوره في
اعماق الجبال تقع على بعد 100 ميلي فقط
شمالي مضيق هرمز الاستراتيجي وتجثه فيها
الطائرات المقاتله والقاذفات والمسيرات
بحسب الخبراء
لكنها ليست الاولى من نوعها ويبدو انها لن
تكون الاخيره